the East is plagued with mystics who
claimed many dread powers but proved
only one separating the foolish from
their purses not so with the renowned
warlocks of calf they demand a much
dearer coin in return for their parlor
tricks
respect once the warlocks truly were
mighty also they would have us believe I
do not doubt they have many secrets they
are an old order and one does not obtain
a seat on the thirteen the Governing
Council of calf without making 12 of our
most powerful citizens afraid to forbid
it thankfully for carve the warlocks
exert little influence in our politics
they rarely leave the confines of the
house of the undying a pompous name but
I admit a strange and dark tower it is
said that none who enter ever leave of
course
since there are no visible doors I have
to believe none ever enter either we can
only imagine what the warlocks do inside
I wager we do not have to imagine much
they read dusty Scrolls detailing their
lost glory they sip shade of the evening
a foul concoction brewed from the nearby
trees until their lips turn blue the
better to frighten children and the
ignorant stirring in their fantasies
like an an old soldier who drinks alone
so no one may challenge their prowess
whatever the Warlocks may wish their
magic like all magic is dead in the
world if it ever existed though one does
hear strange whispers of late glass
candles that have been cold for a
hundred years now burning ghost grass
found far from the lands of the shadow
a khalasar led by a woman with three
heads
traders nonsense most likely but should
the Warlocks vaunted magic ever returned
that would be a dangerous day for Kaif I
shall need to keep my eyes on them
indeed